tonight we'll be going over the top ten
responses to 1d for what opening will be
the most popular let's see what your
guesses are maybe you'll be surprised
this is chess openings explained boom
boom boom oh oh wow wow alright yeah
exactly
okay so yet tonight we are going to be
doing another top 10 list this was
requested by several people the one that
I saw first was my roof Sarkar who-who
wrote waiting for top 10 most popular
responses to 1d for chess openings
explained jonathan morales also said
that would be awesome so for you guys
that's what we will be doing and we will
do this a little bit differently than we
did for our top 10 efore openings we're
actually going to go into specific
variations and you'll see what I mean in
just a moment but when we did the e4
video we covered like 99% of all II four
games tonight we're only going to cover
51.9%
of d4 games so you better request
obscure d4 openings top 10 list if you
want to see that but let's get right to
it coming in at number 10 we have the
Queens gambit accepted which in my
database of almost two and a half
million games that started with one d4
it's been played fifty-three thousand
times or about two point one nine
percent of the games so you don't see it
a whole lot but it is kind of fitting
that the the first one that we're going
to look at tonight is what happens when
you accept the gambit almost all of
these openings tonight white is going to
play d4 and c4 that's what he's trying
to do and whenever you encounter a
gambit for the very first time the big
question you want to ask is well what
happens if I accept it I will try to
understand you know why isn't this as
popular as say protecting it with one of
your pawns so let's take a look at it
the Queens gambit accepted so black
voluntarily takes away from the center
and his aim isn't to play b5 and just
hold on to that pawn forever because
that normally just doesn't work out for
him white almost always regains the pawn
if the machines very sensitive so I I
can't be putting it on the board but if
you can imagine be five white it usually
tacks it with a four and be three
breaking up the queenside and even if
you don't get the pawn back which you
usually do you do get terrific
compensation and the fact that the whole
Queen side is opening up and that's
where white has more space so you might
be surprised that the most popular move
in this position is actually Knight to
f3 which prevents black in all sorts of
lines from playing the move e5 even if
it's a pawn gambit White's just going to
play III and he's going to take on c4
and not allow black to a free his
position here with the move e5 alright
Knight f6 III ecigs and now since you
voluntarily given away the center black
needs to come up with some sort of way
to attack the center when you give your
opponent's the center you want to be
able to attack it otherwise they just
get the center for free white does at
the moment have more central pawns so
black is thinking I'm going to play the
move c5 and I'll be able to attack the
center and that is indeed what happens
in this position
alright so very often he'll be able to
take on d4 and isolate the D pawn so
white here can castle and you might be
thinking well you put this pawn on e6 so
what's to become of this bishop well
blacks plan for this guy is to play a
six and if allowed b5 and the bishop
will go on to the long diagonal where
he'll actually be quite useful so after
a six it's possible to just you know
play a simple move like Knight to c3 or
something but the most testing way is to
prevent b5 with the move
a4 okay so black will will develop and
now if you haven't seen this position
this move might surprise you a little
bit the Queen moves away from protection
of the deep on so it now appears that
black is attacking the deep on three
times and it's only protected twice so
black takes it but what the move the
whites counting on in this position is
rook to d1 and now he'll be able to take
back on the next move so after some more
developing moves we take back you get
the an isolated pawn position and after
a few more moves here black will
continue with a plan either of Knight d4
to d5 this is a very common technique
when you're playing against the isolated
D pawn you might also consider starting
with Knight to d5 and what should
objectively have a slight edge in this
position he does have some really nice
squares for his pieces the knight has a
nice home the bishop is going to be able
to get out the rook is going to enter
the game and white will be playing for
an attack and black will be playing to a
hold on survive the attack and in the
long run this deep on may end up being a
weakness so for people that like playing
these positions as a good opening for
you so that's it that's the Queens
gambit accepted alright coming in at
number nine we have the Trump offski
which is has been seen in 56,000 games
accounting for two point three four
percent of all d4 games and this is the
only opening that made the list that
doesn't begin with d4 c4 instead after
d4 Knight f6 Bishop to g5 and there are
several ways you can play against this
the most popular is the most aggressive
move Knight to e4 also very playable six
is popular d5 c5
these are all candidate moves in this
position but Knight to e4 leads to some
very interesting and exciting positions
okay the first thing is right you're
attacking my my bishop and white and
black will either continue with d5 or c5
in the near future
d5 tending to be the more solid approach
c5 leading to the more aggressive
positions and white already has to make
a choice where are you going to put your
bishop
it is possible which should be mentioned
to play h4 and allow them to take your
bishop in an effort to open the H file
but the two main choices are Bishop to
f4 or Bishop to h4 and at the the top
level overwhelmingly the most popular is
Bishop to f4
but we'll take a look here try to
understand why we'll take a look at
Bishop to h4 alright black now can
aggressively attack the center to move
c5 attacking the dark squares because
white is very likely to weaken some of
the dark squares in his position in
order to expel this Knight
so he plays the move f3 all right now
you might be thinking he's just going to
go back but this next move might shock
you so brace yourselves
you ready g5
alright glad you made it glad you made
it come on in
alright so the bishop is attacked it
doesn't have anywhere particularly good
to go because anywhere it moves the
knight will be able to take it so white
takes on e4 and King shut the door
please
alright thank you alright
we take the bishop and now let's try to
understand this position so black is
attacking your center of white will
somehow need to consolidate the center
here blacks next plan is to get this
Bishop out to g7 and even to h6 these
are both very possible moves so after
the standard move III Bishop to h6
alright so how are you going to protect
your pawn
the most common way is king to f2 okay
so I mean alright occasionally we're
thinking about this sacrifice bringing
the King into the center but it doesn't
work right now
so alright also black has this idea when
you move your C pawn the Queen will be
able to come out on this diagonal and in
this variation she'll often go to b6
where she's putting some pressure on the
B pond okay so after takes Queen b6 and
white is best advised to just give away
the B to pawn if black wants it he needs
to do something active in order to get
some compensation here so he's not
worried about material Knight to c3 with
a very large and annoying threat of
Knight to d5 so if you just take the B
to pawn here Knight to d5 is actually
quite annoying to be
so blacks should play e6 preventing this
idea and after Knight to f3 we get this
sort of a position where obviously you
right you can go ahead and take the b2
pawn if you want but more common is just
to develop your pieces and we'll see
kind of a theme tonight a lot of these
openings you don't just take stuff
that's hanging you just develop your
pieces and castle so we're going to see
a lot of that tonight and okay in this
position like complain like Bishop to b5
and White has pretty decent pieces but
obviously the fact that this King isn't
incredibly comfortable gives black a lot
of chances here which is why the move
Bishop to h4 if we go back to this
position is not the most popular at the
top level instead most people prefer
Bishop to f4 with a slightly different
game but black starts in the same way c5
other moves are possible he you can play
d5 you can even play g5 here c5 is the
the most popular and it's consistent
with his theme here of attacking the
center ok f3 so Knight f6 is a you know
a decent move this way the bishop isn't
able to take it if he was over here he
could take and double your pawns but a
an accurate move here Queen to a5
forcing white to put a pond on c3 so now
your Knights not going to go to c3
because you put a pond there and alright
so after you deal with the threat of
your knight you're going to be
threatening the positional threat of a
sea takes d4 the knight retreats Knight
too late to d2 and the point will be
revealed after black does take Knight to
b3 alright so you're going to move and
then we're going to be able to take the
D pawn most commonly they go to b6 and
after white takes with the Queen you
know he might get a decent game maybe
he'll be able to play E for soon maybe
he'll be able to double black spawns on
b6 which is the the most common way to
play here so night
see 6 so you do get to double the pons
black is hoping for some compensation
along the a file and he's hoping to get
developed a little bit faster than his
opponent here but after the move made to
d4 black has a very very interesting
move e5 and ok if you take here we take
your bishop and when you move back we'll
kind of leave the position here black
obviously has lots of weaknesses over on
the Queen side and in the center but he
does have some active pieces and white
still has to demonstrate that he knows
how to develop his Kings side so such a
position is really interesting will
white black be able to do something with
his development lead and his initiative
will that turn into something
will white struggle to get his King side
pieces out or will he find a way to
liberate his position get his pieces out
and take advantage of all the weaknesses
in Black's territory over here so that's
the battle and that is the trump offski
all right coming in at number 8 really
aggressive opening the Dutch so this is
the only opening here where black
doesn't either start with d5 or Knight
to f6 and this has been played 86
thousand times or three point five
percent of all d4 games okay
and there's more than one way to play
against the Dutch you can play C four
here you can play Knight to c3 you can
even do the Staunton gambit efore h3 is
even a move just planning on playing g4
sacrificing g4 is a move there's all
sorts of crazy gambits and stuff but the
the most popular response here from
white is g3 okay so with the Dutch it's
a it's interesting black is taking a lot
of space on the Kings side and he's
hoping that he's not weakening too much
stuff
it is interesting kind of when we did
the the Scandinavian I asked is this
sharp solid suspicious people have sort
of the same feelings about the Dutch it
can be solid you know the Stonewall is
about a solid as it gets also it does
lead to some really crazy you know
sacrifices and
really aggressive games what is it
suspicious you know you're moving your
f-pawn doesn't that weaken your king
yeah so it's into you you know people
have all sorts of different feelings
about it okay but now we'll go just a
few more developing moves and black can
consider developing classically ecigs
you know Bishop to e7 and castling
that's one very common way to play in
which case the Queen will be maneuvering
to a queen to e8 to h4 h5 sorry and
getting on with a King side attack but
uh the Leningrad is the most popular way
black is going to put his Bishop on this
very aggressive diagonal and he's going
to castle so here both sides will
develop the pieces pretty pretty
normally and after we castle now white
will play c4 he doesn't tend to take
more space on the Queen side before he
continues and we'll assess the position
after moves d6 and Knight to c3 now
White's plan is to move all over on the
Queen side usually with moves like d5 b
for c5 these are the moves that he's
going to hope to accomplish here very
often he's going to have to get his rook
off of this long diagonal here so that
the bishop never ends up taking him and
black if he's ever able to play the move
e5 is usually doing really well so white
needs to take great care not to allow
this liberating move for black and
alright there's there's more than one
way black can play here
Queen to e8 is the most popular Knight
to c6 also is a very interesting line
we'll take a quick look at the move c6
here in this position white can play the
move d5 getting control over some of
these light squares getting you know a
little bit more space but obviously you
are weakening this diagonal so that
needs to be taken into account so yeah
he has to play e5 and part of the point
of playing d5 was now you can take on
passant and you get a position like this
where your C pawn is attacked you can
defend it with your queen you can get
ready to bring a rook in this is a very
you know interesting way to play black
might consider maneuvering is Knight
and you get a very interesting game but
more popular in this position is Queen
to e8 all right so he's going to play e5
so white needs to stop it by playing d5
there are other moves but generally this
is the principled way to continue
sometimes this Knight will even go where
it controls some of these light squares
as well and right why just going to play
here and here and here that's his plan
okay so sensing that this square was was
recently weakened the knight is going to
jump in as advertised the rook is going
to come over and okay you get an
interesting position we're really trying
to get a grip on the position and at
some point he's going to attack the
center and this is sort of the style of
game that you're going to expect
and at some point black is hoping to get
this move in and launch a King side
attack he's going to get all these pawns
rolling if he ever gets these guys
rolling the Queen will be able to come
over and so sometimes white just wins on
the Queen side and then he just
positionally crushes black and sometimes
black it's a really big attack going so
it's it's a very interesting way to play
that is the Dutch defense coming in at
number seven in opening we talked about
kind of recently the maroon Feld
this has been played eighty eight
thousand times or three point six five
percent of all d4 games so let's get the
Grune fall on the board now in this
position after Knight to c3 white
intends to play the movie four so if you
play Bishop to g7 efore but this is
black's last chance if he wants to put
upon in the center so the way that i
showed last time is the most popular the
exchange variation not the only way to
play but a very principled continuation
you can trade a side pawn for a central
pawn it makes sense to do so
and after they capture efore and after
the trade we start to see the position
unfolding here black's big target is
going to be the d4 pawn he's going to
gang up on
at Bishop to g7 c5 Knight to c6 and he's
going to attack it with everything he
has so I recommended in my other video
Bishop to c4 the point oh it's not just
not going to like that Bishop to c4 the
idea is you can put the night on e - and
you never have to worry about this
Bishop pin because you could play f3 so
that was one way but I did mention
briefly the modern way to play so I will
go over that now Knight to f3 which
surprisingly was thought to be a mistake
for a long time because you are allowing
black to at some point play Bishop to g4
so you can play normal moves c5 Knight
to c6 Castle and then Bishop to g4 and
you're going to run out of defenders of
the D pawn so we'll see what's going to
happen so after c5 the move that you
know revived this opening is rook to b1
the idea being if you move your Bishop
your be pawn is it's going to become
weak here this does often allow a
sacrifice here the a to pawn is a is
likely to be captured by black and it
should be in most lines after C d-four
CD for Queen d5 Bishop d2 Queen a - you
will be losing this pawn and so we will
be checking that out but here
castles some normal moves and it is
advisable that you capture now and play
Queen to a5 and yet you take the a2 pawn
after Knight to c6 which is a you know
seems like a very normal move you know I
don't wanna go in for the gambit white
actually is really well prepared to meet
this with the surprising move d5 okay
and isn't this just given away the C
pawn here well black normally doesn't
take it we'll go back to that variation
but after such a position like and play
the unusual but very strong
Queen to d2 you're going to play f4 get
the big center kick the bishop away so
in continuation
like this he can go back either to c7 or
g7 but wait it's going to get a monster
Center he can play c4 Castle kingside
why should have a very good position in
this line but okay what happens if i
take this pond and yeah so sort of a lot
of lines in this lecture you don't want
to just take stuff it doesn't end up
well you want to develop your pieces and
castle here
Bishop to d2 and you have two pieces
attacked so you have to part with your
your best friend your dark squared
Bishop and now you have to move your
knight okay Knight a5 it's not super
unusual in this opening but it's not
perfectly ideal in this position and you
might like White's next move here h4
here I come play might continue Bishop
to g4 h5 not joking around a big mistake
is taking so you might want to pause
your video and see what white would play
here there's a couple of good moves but
one move is really really strong that
move is g4 okay I'm going to take your
Bishop if you take you're not going to
like Queen to h6 even if you block
Knight to g5 and mate is right around
the corner so okay so here you can take
the knight and white still gets a really
nice attacking position at some point he
will open the H file he's going to get
as Queen into h6 this should be very
pleasant for white which is why back in
this position here after sorry in this
position instead of just developing
Knight to c6 you know casual play can
sometimes especially something as highly
theoretical as the Grune felled land you
in a lot of trouble you should instead
take on d4 throw in the Queen check and
take on a2 and all right well castle and
we'll take a look at this position here
so black is up upon and he has a two to
zero majority on the Queen
so that's pretty good but will white be
able to do something with his big lead
in development that's going to be the
real test okay so I have to remove like
Bishop to g4
you should resist the urge to play rook
takes b7 and now it sort of seems like
what the thing is but don't just take
stuff you should develop your pieces and
castle if you play rook takes b7 let's
see if we can we can imagine it he will
take your knight and when you take back
your D pawn will be hanging so don't you
don't want to just rush in and take
stuff
the main move here is actually Bishop to
g5 which provokes h6 before going to e3
now you might be wondering what if I
just take stuff but again don't just
take stuff put your pieces on good
squares if you take this after you'll
move like this you know it seems like
you're doing really well you took both
the pawns but actually black stands a
little bit better in this variation so
even after some some normal moves if you
lose this guy then you're probably not
doing well that the center was what's
the big thing that you had there so you
got to be careful you know you're not
just gentlemen just take stuff and
especially if you've never even seen
this in your opponent plays h6 here they
know full well their pawns hanging so
you better be careful think about what
they're they're planning well he's
trying to convince you to trade some
pawn so he can get your big Center and
not weaken your position so just put
your pieces on good squares now the
threat of taking on b7 is real but again
in this position I can show Rick to b7
if you take here he's going to get one
of these files for his rooks and then
his rook is coming down to the second
rank you can try to stay on the 7th rank
but after looking up to c8 you're kind
of compelled to trade here and then he
gets the better pieces even though you
do get up on back instead d5 is the main
move and after such a move
Bishop to c5 so again you're attacking
the e pawn but I can say go ahead take
it and there is a very unique line here
that I do want to show after you take
he's going to attack and you might be
thinking d6 isn't this isn't this pretty
good for white but now Knight to c6
seems okay I pin you and so now probably
I'm going to like win in exchange here
if you move your knight well black can
take and I quite like this idea here so
you can take on e85 or move here
that's cute you'll notice that Knight
doesn't have any where it can move so
you can play the move h3 and even if he
takes you steal your turn but you have
nowhere to move your knight if if you go
here you want protect your rook and
there's just nowhere else to go so now
you will take the exchange next move and
you'll take on e7 and yeah this is the
kind of thing you can expect when you
play the Grune field in the group photo
in particular don't just take the pawns
get your pieces to good squares it
usually tends to matter a lot more than
just being greedy and winning material
alright coming in at number six we have
the Queen's Indian which has been played
in 91 thousand games very close to
ninety two thousand or three point seven
eight percent of all d4 openings okay so
we'll get back to a position that's
reached several times now most white
people white players will play Knight to
c3 here and you might get the nihms oh
but I can also try to avoid these lines
by playing Knight to f3 okay so now you
can play the Danny Machuca specialty the
BOGO Indian you know he loves he loves a
good check how can you resist a
perfectly good check well the most
popular move here for black is actually
b6 with the idea of putting this bishop
perhaps on b7 where you control the e4
square which
is very crucial in this line or you
might even go all the way to a6 with
some inconvenient pressure on the C pond
there are a couple different ways white
can play if you play Knight to c3
probably after Bishop to b4 you NIM so
players will be happy a3 the Petrosian
variation that's a very decent way to
play but g3 this is the other fianchetto
variation is the most popular and you
might be surprised to learn that the
main move is not Bishop to b7 but Bishop
to a6 the exaggerated fianchetto there's
absolutely nothing wrong with Bishop to
b7 and this opening black is just really
solid and it tends to lead to sort of
dry boring positions so we'll breeze
through it we'll just get through it and
black is not committed to anything in
the center yet he's waiting he's letting
white see how he wants to set up and now
black can trade some pieces and I get a
relatively equal position which all
right we have to focus get a little more
gain a little time here so we'll just
breeze through this one you can see it's
just you know sparring it's a normal
position black is comfortably equalized
so they're players that you like to play
really solid then this is a good opening
choice for you also rather solid is the
the bishop to a6 line though there are
some complications that are possible now
a bishop to a6 the reason you might play
this you think well White's just going
to defend this pawn but it's not
actually a super convenient way to do it
playing III doesn't really make sense
after you've played g3 Knight B to d2 or
even Knight f2 d2 doesn't make a lot of
sense walking in your bishop so b3 is
the most popular way to play Queen to a4
is very possible but after Bishop to b7
you know they're saying okay what's your
queen doing over there on on a4 I will
show one gambit line briefly there's a
move that sort of recently become pretty
popular in the Queen to c2 line here
and after black attacks in the center to
move white wants to play is d5 but
unfortunately it's protected twice but
unfortunately for black white can
sacrifice so this is becoming a
fashionable line so you are gamba ting
upon and black has really advised to
play Bishop to b7 if we play here a
blunder so who can who can solve this
tactic in the audience yeah you're right
exactly
yep yeah Queen to d4 so even if the
knight moves back as mentioned yet the
rook is hanging so okay so instead he
goes back and we develop and now the
piece the Pawnee is actually hanging and
all right for time I guess I won't go
too much into the line but there's been
some really aggressive games White's
attack can come actually surprisingly
quickly he's going to get a quick
efore t5 in the rook comes to d1 you
know the knight comes out Bishop moves
out and you can get a surprisingly good
attack so there's been some really
decent high-level games in that position
but uh we'll look very briefly at b3 the
most popular move and you're likely to
get a very you know it's when you play
this opening this is what you hope for
you get a position like this super solid
what doesn't have a whole lot here he's
maybe a smidge better but a super solid
opening so a decent way to play for
black if you're trying to equalize all
right coming in at number 5 we got the
benoni with 94,000 games or three point
eight seven percent of all d4 games so
for the benoni
after Knight here so one way to play
this position is to attack the center
immediately with the move c5 and after
d5 we've reached the benoni
now we've covered the Bangko gambit
which is actually the most common way
for black to play in this position so b5
sac
pricing upon is the most common way to
play so for a change we'll look at the
modern benoni which is the movie six and
we can see the the plans for both sides
after we reach this position the clothes
center makes it really easy to
understand where both sides should be
playing Black has more space on the
Queen side so you can expect a 6 B 5
coming up and white intends C 4 f 4e 5
breaking through in the center so
sometimes white just plays in the center
and squashes black but sometimes black
it's enough counter play on the Queen
side and so there's a certain style of
player that you know is really suited
they like to play this get a lot of
counter-attacks and they don't mind an
aggressive white player trying to just
storm home and crush them right away the
most popular move here is e for not the
only move and now it's time for black to
decide what he's going to do with this
Bishop probably doesn't belong on e7
trap behind the pawns so when you play
d5 you weaken this diagonal so the
bishop is going to come to g7 all right
now you can play Knight f3 followed by
either you know Bishop e2 and castling
or h3 and castling but the the most
critical way is f4 I'm just going to
play e5 and I'm going to crush you
okay so we reach this position black was
just about to castle so you could play
Knight f3 here but you can play one
interfering move so Bishop to b5 and
it's a lot of people here they might
make a mistake with black because the
obvious moves are either to put this
knight here or the bishop here but those
are both bad for the same reason so the
main move is actually Knight F to d7 but
let's look at that a little little more
closely so what's wrong with Knight B to
d7
well now the move e5 comes and white is
better in this line for example you can
take the knight has to move ecigs
okay but does black have some tricks up
his sleeve it is going to get
complicated after Queen h4 check if you
play g3 doesn't black have a very
well-known trick here Knight takes g3
well guess
white is intending to for the moment for
go with the rook so we're going to lose
in exchange here but you have lots of
pieces hanging on d7 so take my rook
you're attacking my my knight I could
take on d7 right now or it can simply
protect my knight and you can't really
castle because I'm taking on d7 so you
can weaken my Queen side not the only
move might seem a little controversial
to give away that big bishop but he's
hoping now if white ever castles Queen
side that he won't be terrifically safe
and then he should force the issue and
you should trade on d7 and you reach a
really complicated position but why it
should be better here so well-prepared
player should do quite well with the
white pieces here which is why the
unusual-looking Knight F to d7 is played
in this position okay
a4 again you might have thought Knight
to f3 was coming but if you just play
Knight f3 black intends a 6 and b5 so a4
prevents that idea and now again there's
2 moves so you can castle or you can
play a Queen to h4 check castling is the
more common we'll try to understand why
so here you know you're provoking g3 but
you have wasted some time with your
Queen maneuver so we'll get to the the
main position here after you Castle
blacks plan is Knight to a6 and he's
looking at going to one of two squares
now in this Queen at the when the Queen
check line white has time to play rook
e1 which won't be true in the castling
line so any variations with Knight to c7
won't be as effective because the bishop
has the f1 Square and it can go to g2 or
h3 and make an appearance
over on the kingside so black will
almost always go for the night to be
four lines which does add a little bit
of pressure white will voluntarily
retreat the bishop and how are you ever
going to get a five a six and B five in
well commonly be six not so much to play
Bishop a5 and trade more to just develop
the bishop to be seven before either
putting a knight rook on on the B file
and playing here or swinging the rook
all the way over to get more pressure on
the e pawn
by contrast we'll look back at this
position and we'll cast it's not gonna
get real castle so in this line you'll
notice now you you do have this move
which again is a common enough way to
play play might continue as follows will
just breeze through for time and you'll
notice this is a in it's an aggressive
attacking plan for white he maneuvers
the bishop over to f2 where it'll make
an appearance over on the Queen side
sometimes it'll go to g3 so that you can
play the movie five sometimes it'll go
to h4 harassing the Queen so in the
Queen check line that's one thing that
you prevent it you provoke the move g3
so I just want playing the e prevented
but more common and I know I'm going
quick but we don't have a whole lot of
time here so Knight to c7 and you don't
get to retreat to f1 instead you have to
go to say d3 and now the plan for black
is to get the move b5 in he's going to
play rook to b8 and from c7 not only
does the knight keep a watchful eye over
the d5 square but he's also watching
over b5 so he will try in the future to
get the move b5 in and you'll get such a
position white is ready to play e5 all
of this pieces are ready for it
and the big question will be will it
just blow black off the board or does he
have enough going on on the Queen side
so a very interesting opening and we'll
have to leave it there for today coming
in at number four we
the semi Slav with ninety five and a
half thousand games or three point nine
three percent of all games so again
we're removing up the list but we're
still only three percent of all the
games here the semi Slav okay so we'll
look at this move obviously a very
decent way you know you protect the pawn
of the center Knight f3 is the most
common move here after Knight to c3
which is very possible you do need to
know moves like D takes c4 and even the
move e5 the win or a counter gambit but
this moves sort of prevents that if you
take on c4 you were to get back into
sort of a Queens gambit accepted line so
in this position C takes d4 would be the
Slav which just barely didn't make the
list
ISA --cs the semi Slav is what we're
going to be looking at today a position
that I quite like for both sides the
move that's the most aggressive and
perhaps the best way to try for an
advantage is Bishop to g5 but we're
going to take a look at the slightly
more popular III and in particular half
of the games that go this way will lead
to the Moran which black weights sort of
a move is sort of a half waiting move
he's waiting for a white to decide what
he's going to do with this Bishop
because as soon as the bishop moves he's
going to take on c4 and if the bishop
takes back play an early b5 to get this
Bishop out so Queen to c2 would be a
totally different line here it's a it's
a perfectly good waiting move for white
and black has to think about a different
setup but today we're going to look at
Bishop to d3 okay so now black will take
and this is now the Moran so after you
take back b5 and there's all three of
these retreats our moves but Bishop to
d3 by far the most popular how are we
doing on time Bensimon 45 in all right
we've got to pick up so in this position
the plan for black is a6 solidifying the
b-pawn and c5 also he wants to put the
bishop on b7
so there's two moves here you can play a
six immediately or Bishop to b7 Bishop
to b7 is the more popular let's take a
quick look and unfortunately it has to
be very quick
so here white can castle but then black
plays c5 I don't have time to show it
will just show one of the main moves
here which is e for trying to cause
black some problems immediately
so if c5 d5 is the most popular response
it is worth looking at at some of these
lines here cladding this line is a very
interesting way to play and there's
there's a lot of sacrifices that are
going to happen right here in the
opening because he takes on d4 and now
you can take on b5 so you know very
aggressive stuff eat black and take here
I've even had a opponent play this move
against me the most popular is to take
and after we take back black takes with
his Jeep on will have to breeze through
it again don't just take stuff develop
your pieces and castle castling is what
gives black or white the the best
percentage of wins in this line so
that's that's the recommended move and
we'll have to go quite quickly here but
you get such a position white will
eventually play the move a 4 and in my
personal experience I've done quite well
here with white I played it as both
colors but it's a very interesting way
to play but I will try to go quickly
through this line do not be tempted to
take don't just take stuff develop your
pieces because after this move e5
followed by a quick Bishop to g5 and
we're taking taking here and white gets
a really good position can't show to
show everything but okay after taking in
here you get a very interesting position
where unlike the bishop to b7 line that
we'll take a look at in a second this
pawn is indirectly defended by the
bishop so a lot of lines where you
attack this power
early aren't going to be as effective
which also means the night doesn't need
to go to c5 here the bishop does okay
and now the crucial squared to think
about here is e five that's the move
that white wants to play so if he gets
to play that he's usually doing pretty
good and black can deter him for a
little bit by putting a piece on e5 and
after this exchange we want to play f4
and E five so King h1 getting out of the
pen and in such a position we do get to
play e5 and we're threatening to trap
the Knight g5 though is an interesting
way to play okay so in such a line you
know things are the night isn't trapped
over here both sides have some weak
stuff it's a very interesting endgame
that I wish we had time for all right
we'll try to get back to the the main
modern line here now what usually
castles efore isn't as effective i guess
well because you haven't wasted a tempo
with a six so just this lines a little
bit better for black don't have too much
time so we'll just let's get to the the
main stuff here castling is recommended
if he for as in the other line with a
bishop on b7 it's a little bit different
because alright they just cut that
little part out all right
Bishop to b7 white will castle a6 he's
going to play C v e4 and again you can
choose from two moves d5 is the the most
common there's a little bit of a
difference here if you play e5 based on
the fact that you're your Bishop is over
here on b7 so as seen in the the
following line if you take here black
and throw in the move Bishop takes f3
and the point is after he moves us night
he's going to take here and black simply
can't be worse here he's going to pick
up the bishop on d3 get his Bishop out
and castle
and he's definitely not worse here
but okay d5 again don't just take stuff
develop your pieces so in this line
again so this is a very important move
actually you're trying to control the e5
square and after these captures the
knight will go here not the only move
but it's the most common and perhaps the
most critical and so you'll have to
defend this pawn with the night and
unfortunately we'll have to leave it
there there's some some pretty exciting
stuff here but I think we got a got to
pick it up see Ben Simon over there
looking at this phone so coming in at
number 3 we have the nimzo-indian which
we have we just covered here last week
so now we're getting serious 153,000
games or 6.3 1% of all games so we'll
just jump right to it here all right
Bishop to b4 indirectly controlling the
e4 square so preventing away from
playing e4 due to the pin and we covered
the move Queen to c2 so today we'll take
a real brief look over III and that we
will be quick not only for time but I do
intend to at some point here do a whole
lecture on that this move the Rubinstein
variation the main moves here are
castling and let's just take a quick
look at some of the the sidelines here
because they're they're quite
interesting b6 is an interesting move
White's intentions in these lines
normally he's either going to develop
normally or he's going to play a move
like Knight to d2 to prevent doubling
the pawns and you'll follow that up with
a 3 so in this line okay if we if we
develop normally we get some normal
position but let's just look at this
line here because that's of interest now
black can play Bishop to a6 and after a
three if you just retreat back to e7 you
can get sort of a an exciting line the
knight comes in
and in this position well you can play
King takes f1 or the very interesting
taking on e6 and if you retreat your
Bishop we take on f7 and there's two
ways to play here you can play Queen to
b3 after King to e8 Knight to d6 that's
a very annoying thing also Aronian has
had this position and he preferred to
movie for you played an early 45 but for
brevity here let's go ahead and we'll
take a quick look at another popular
line c5 and one of the points here black
is going to establish his pawns on the
dark squares so just to give you a quick
look at what that might look like after
some normal developing moves so he is
doubled White's pawns he's never really
worried about the move d5 though
sometimes white will end up playing it
because closing the center will be good
for him and then the fact that you're
doubled pawns might actually end up
hurting you
so white usually will you know for those
long as you can keep the tension and
here he can sort of wait after the
following moves he can play a move like
rook to be won the point is sometimes
after we play aggressive moves like f4
trying to get an attack going black
might take this pawn and then our pawn
will have to move and then black will
you know try to jump into some of these
squares you know for example b4 and
sometimes you'll have a queen on c2 and
you want to be able to sacrifice the
exchange just to give you a quick in a
really brief view this is what happens
and okay so white gets it a little
attack going and he's going to play on
the King side but coming in at number 2
we have the Queens gambit declined with
a very large portion of games 204,000
games or 8.4 2% I thought this was going
to be the the most common opening but uh
but I was wrong this one that's even
more popular perhaps by now you've
figured it out
or if you're smart enough you just went
down in the info below and you read
what's all the openings are okay the
Queens gambit declined alright so one of
the most solid ways to play and we'll
briefly touch on all of these variations
here we looked at this position before
and I recommended the move C takes d5
the exchange variation and showed how
that's one of White's best ways to play
for an advantage and all of the main
lines that occur after Bishop to g5 have
a very very solid reputation which
explains why it's so popular alright so
some very normal moves and black now has
some options Knight B to d7 is the
Orthodox defense and he's again waiting
for the bishop to move before you take
on c4 Y can make a nice waiting move
rook testing one usually the C file is
going to open up so the rook will be
good there eventually and after the
following moves now he takes he can play
what's often known as the kappa blanka
freeing maneuver and now we trade all of
the pieces and we get a very solid
endgame alright he gets the move e5 in
and okay you get a position like this
where there's not much for either side
but fans of playing end games or you
know certain positions like this they
like playing these really solid
positions where the computer will assess
it as perfectly equal but knowing the
the themes and ideas in the opening will
matter the most so for certain certain
type of people this is the opening for
you all right we'll jump back here most
often black will insert this move it's a
very useful move what are you going to
do with your bishop you can take on f6
but that most people will play here
I am the Charter tower is the most
popular we'll mention also the Alaska
variation again we trade all of the
pieces and we get you know roughly the
same ending where this happens again
so we're noticing some similarities here
instead b6 the Charter tower this is the
most popular unsurprisingly we trade
everything
and so you're with the pawn on d5 you're
at least saying well now Fischer to be
seven doesn't make a lot of sense
black will have to try for something
like c5 obviously at the moment if you
play C five D takes e5 and your D pawn
is hanging so Bishop to e6 and now white
does have a cute little maneuver that's
worth knowing
Queen to a4 after c5 will understand the
point mm-hmm yeah Queen to a3
okay so pending the pawn we'll have to
leave it here all right coming in at
number one we have the King's Indian
this has been played three hundred and
thirty six thousand times or a whopping
thirteen point eight five percent of all
d4 games alright so I wonder if you guys
were able to predict at home that this
was going to be the the most popular
opening we see here g6 after Knight to
c3 Bishop to g7 allowing wait to get the
big pond Center castling as possible as
demonstrated by Fisher but d6
overwhelmingly the main choice we have
covered the classical variation before
so unfortunately we do have to be quick
d5 is possible but then black can play a
five-night to at a six and the knight to
c5 so normally he waits until black
provokes them and we've seen this
position before and we've studied the
line Knight to e1 which has the idea of
playing moves like f3 and Bishop to F 3
to F 2 defending against blacks oncoming
attack he's going to play over here on
the Kings side and get all of his pawns
rolling and try to checkmate white
before white crashes through on the
Queen side so when you play this way and
you're playing as white either you get
checkmated or you win on the Queen side
and then black just flounders around and
you slowly strangle them to death so for
a change
we'll look at the move B for the bayonet
attack also a very popular move
and a move that's saying okay you can do
what you need to do on the kingside I'll
do what I need to do on the queenside
and I'll just get right to it I'm going
to have to play c5 at some point so I'm
just going to do what I want to do so
the most popular response from black is
to get on with his idea and he's going
to play a 5 another possible alternative
though that's worth mentioning whenever
you play before you want to be thinking
about what happens if they play a 5
obviously if you play just be 5 after B
6 you have no counter play on the
queenside so this would be dreadful
you see play Bishop to a3 taking on a5
it's also an idea but this is a stronger
way to play after taking you're ready to
play C 5 but a Knight to d7 eyeing the
the C 5 square trying to make it hard
for you and alright you get more space
over here you're going to play a 5 and
this is an interesting move black
intends to play f5 but whenever he plays
f5 he needs to worry about the following
maneuver and even if you're sacrificing
upon it's it's so common to put that
night on e6 where you're going to have
to give up your Bishop which is actually
one of your strongest attackers in these
lines and you're opening up lines on the
in the center and on the Queen side so
this is what he's up preventing with the
move Bishop to h6
all right and you could get such a
position not the only way to play and
now you finally get to move c5 in and
white is much better in the following
continuation all right you get this
position this pawn is a bit weak we have
constant pressure here we got the all
these open files on the Queen side look
like you know he will get some active
play but uh but why should be better in
this line okay but now back to the main
line here
Knight aged 5 and he's heading to the f4
square potentially so for a long time
the move that was played here was g3 to
prevent you know the knight from coming
in here to f4 is thought okay
my f4 is just too strong you have to
prevent it and weaken your king side but
crane Nick really popularized this
variation again he invent it but you
know he he added some new ideas and his
idea was rook to e1 so the point is now
if Knight to f4
we can play Bishop to f1 okay let's get
let's get to it here f5 here he comes
and we jump in we're going into e6 even
if it costs us the pawn ok I'll just
briefly mention if Knight to f4 you can
take in a play rook to c1 and you'll
play c5 soon
what can't go any more more depth at the
moment unfortunately and ok we'll get in
a position like this the bishop actually
makes a lot of sense on f3 because the e
pawn and the deep on are likely to move
in the future and unfortunately the game
here is just starting this is sort of
the starting point for the variation but
it's the ending point for our lecture so
yeah so thank you guys for coming that's
those are the most popular responses to
d4 again I will be filling in for Mike
comer for the whole month of April so if
you do have games you want to see
analyzed send them in to info at st.
Louis chess club org and maybe you'll
get to see it on one of these shows as
usual send in your submissions what
opening do you guys want to see next
what top 10 lists do you guys want to
see next please hit like share subscribe
and thanks everybody for coming out to
my
Oh